Một tháng 10 tháng 10, chúng mình chưa tiên cà xe nữa, cho biết, phó triệu mang trước khi anh chưa gần đạo động,
chưa tiên kiếm yêu trong nhấn mạnh, sôn không thể tránh nè chính giảm đô viết mấy bây con người lại URV sâm nhập không phận nước này.
Chua tiên cho sang qua về đất y lại những hình nè, càng vì các khu công nghiệp có sự hạ tân và trạm gác người điên giới.
Bình nhóm khẳng định chính nghiệm quan Quốc không phụ thuộc vào việc URV, gió quân đội hay cá nhân dân sự điều kiện.
Đông thời yêu cầu chấm rất càng đậm mà họ cho là khíu khích.
Bây phần mình, bố Quốc phòng anh Quốc hàng định của nổi không chỉnh khai URV sâm nhập không phận chủ tiên.
Và mẫu URV xuất hiện chúng các hình nèng gió phía chủ tiên công bố không thủ biến trẻ của nổi hành quốc.
Chỉnh của anh cũng đã thích lập tổ điều chá, và tổng thống liên trên miền nhấn mạnh, nếu cám buộc là chính xác,
đây sẽ lành đi đi bạn vào lượng miếng trọng, đây gió hòa biên và o định trên bà đảo chủ tiên.
Đông thời sôn hàng định không cối đi khu khích, và câm kế tức tục nỗ lực giảm càng thẳng liên chíu.